um you know what I do I'll order our
coffee when I don't even want one just
so I can feel the warmth in my hand I'll
sip on it throw most of it away and then
I'll order a chocolate chip cookie
that's way too big very thick full of
chocolates nice I'll take a small bite
I'll take a small blind all cleaned up
I'll nibble up then I play clean up and
then you play clean up by the rabbit I
leave it out there batter up
thank God play clean up on the 4th
batter heavy line up our stick man
you're probably the first guy to dig
that's right then I'm the cleanup you
clean up and I clean that coat well
you're celebrating now Brendan got there
and we had some pastries and Brennan
goes have take that then I'll take that
and I'll take another one I go hold well
you don't like me that's very unlike you
what's going on he goes haven't eaten I
don't know what's going on and goes and
let me get that one too I got bro we get
him carrot crazy and he goes and what's
that guy goes that's a chive scone and
he goes throw that in there too and I
was like what the [ __ ] is going on he
had a baby
he had Boston came into the world in J
Boston Boston Shea came into the world
who was in the room when Boston Jake
came came to be just me his mama yep and
then the doctors and nurses did you get
our doctors 9,000 years old yeah I know
I don't
yeah I don't really vibe with them it's
not about me is it it's not about you
not me it's about Joanna
I don't vibrate them in what sense you
just old he just tells the long the
story sure all time sure he's bilingual
so Joanna likes that Thanks he's been
doing it for 1,000 years
literally he's a tortoise yeah he's a
torte he's probably doing doctors a
human tortoise probably delivered I
would say practice every day it was a
chance he could have delivered
no yes pictures he told it 50,000 days
something the thousands that so he knows
I've seen every complication everything
whatever goes wrong I've seen it before
I'm not gonna freak out and but he's
bilingual and he's like he's like really
warming and Karen he's just too old for
me just too old yeah you know like he's
82 I think was old for Doc offered or
for a doctor but Joanna dug him so much
that's not my [ __ ] ordeal with years
old you do too
still doing still doing it that's all
right I mean oh dude they say you want
you want when someone is looking at your
x-rays
you want someone young here's why
someone with gray hair seen a lot of
x-rays and they tend to gloss over so
just one thing I read they tend to
kolosso over the they're not as careful
they're not as young and enthusiastic a
young a young doctor is gonna look at
every eye trying to catch everything
yeah okay now when it comes time to
cutting you though you want a guy with
gray hair because a surgeon how about no
hair though how about a few hairs well
you don't want any hair getting in your
abdomen well this guy's a few hairs yeah
well you don't want Jason Momoa with
that long hair cuz a couple strands I
backed a couple of long strands are kind
of fun you know I didn't like then you
know it's got a high-pressure situation
everyone's a little bit on edge except
for the nurses and doctors because I've
done it 1,000 times all they do and I
told one nurse when we finally you know
baby's fine we're in the back I go you
what do you do now she goes oh we have
another seven deliveries today by sport
climbing guy this saw you do everyday
strokes every day I go oh so for you it
ain't [ __ ] yes no we see this all the
time all the time yeah she is all the
time but uh oh so when the baby's coming
I know stay add music God you know
enjoying us coherent she's under the
knife but she you know she has stuff in
her but she's going she knows exactly
what's going on
the nurses I'm Todd nourishes I hear the
music and it's pretty it's loud where
you know it's loud we gotta yell to talk
and stuff I guess the only other things
without louder say like music that
beating their need okay that's weird
well I was like all right and then they
it was kind of again it's not about me
but they go oh he needs scrubs to go in
their room oh yeah okay they gave me
scripts last time that fit yeah and then
she goes oh oh wow
I don't man I don't know if we have
scrubs that fit you oh well it's my
second roadie odd they had scrubs at the
last Hospital she goes well it's gonna
be tough it's gonna be tough she get
something in front of everybody else
yeah no no he's a large one yeah I know
he's little he's a large one and I was
like oh this [ __ ] [ __ ] that's how
we're doing this so then she brings me
the stuff doesn't fit any capacity now
so you know this is so embarrassing you
know what they had to do tie several
scrubs around each leg body is that
right oh it look I looked so stupid like
the mommy it's so [ __ ] stupid
eirick eirick - my son's gonna come in
like who the [ __ ] is this idiot
who's this idiot with the weird scrub
that's so already I'm mad at that and
then the music John I'm like I don't
like that song I just say anything next
song like you definitely don't like that
song yeah I remember it was like the
first song was like one of those train
songs you know and I was like yeah
that's a little gay whatever I must fear
yeah yeah and I go how long till date
comes ago probably about seven minutes
I'm like rights that's right three songs
so I'm like if the next song super gay
like that one I'm left to say some cuz I
want my son come in this world to
[ __ ] nipple backers yeah [ __ ] cuz I
asked the guy go who the anesthesiology
was a young guy and I go hey man who's
playlist is it's heõs oh it's it's you
know it's just it's somebody's here I
didn't put it on I go do you know what
songs are next he goes no I have no idea
it's like Pandora your wife's wanna make
sure you know it's not just make sure
it's not something super lame as my son
comes in or gangster rap we're hearing
[ __ ] and [ __ ] my sister stymie comes he
hears Nickelback yeah or [ __ ] three
Doors Down I so understand that I so
understand oh I keep coming to a neutral
right I was gonna be quiet
oz I can't let him do this thing I went
but how about no [ __ ] this no I went hey
is everybody can make sure whatever song
that's he's coming like three minutes
give me the psalm artistically what does
it looks like a little pump or some
[ __ ] you know what I agree it's not
it's kind of a pain you know yeah it's a
big moment no we did little journey
there yeah yeah yeah yeah classic
journeys I know I need something that
just a small town no that's what I did
man here comes Bob Boston he's got a
he's got a dick on yeah I seen it I
didn't say in the picture
huge issue they're certainly pulling out
I go there's all female nurses on I
don't want to cross the line there I
went that kid gets a dick and balls on
though am i right
they all started laughing I went you see
babies that kid has a dick on him they
says it's not small like this no
don't I have a mask I couldn't see the
tongue yeah I wish you'd be quiet
throwing that [ __ ] playlist came on
I was like we'll figure out in like how
about know what a [ __ ] Nickelback you
didn't get emotional when the baby came
out no not really
cuz it's let you know it's my second
time you were sending money tech this
timeless wave this time was way better
yeah yeah just the hospital's way better
I didn't your emotional skylight cedar
siding okay big boy moves cedar cyanide
and yeah I didn't get I got none I
didn't get that no I didn't get
emotional I cried when Tiger came out I
liked him better and yeah I don't know
it's it's a weird feeling man it's a
weird feeling I almost feel like I'm
like last night I was with tiger and I
was like explaining the data I'm showing
a picture of his brother and he's like
when we FaceTime he's like laughs and
he's like Boston wake up like yelling at
him and then we got and I felt like I
told my girl like I feel like we're
cheating on Tiger yeah like made-up [ __ ]
you know because there were you all day
you know yeah I went through that well
we were all casual about the second baby
casual like the first baby that came she
said she said man said my water broke
and I go and you know you going to you
going to she did that when you're going
to like yeah you going to war mode fight
or flight you don't you don't panic at
all I just was like three in the morning
okay
okay yeah I get him [ __ ] we just
getting my [ __ ] I get her all in the car
we go
and then it's a 24-hour process she has
the baby the next like four in the monka
but I had people in there Dov her cousin
oh wow a friend where did you it was a
party oh you party oh you're so old as
[ __ ] saina you can't there's only only
the only the father or mother's allowed
in the room now really there's only one
person and then even after like the
baby's born when they're in the recovery
room only one person can be in the room
and then once you get out until like the
regular Dan's gonna physics liability
[ __ ] you can't have any of that now man
we had all my friend I appreciate it
yeah cuz it's there's a lot going on man
come on Amanda come on come on boys come
on come on whose idea and then the baby
came out again looked like an Inuit yeah
they look very strange like my son when
he get when they pull him out you hear
him crying and he's like a loud
which what you want but they're like
they're like a dark purple like he's /
yeah and then you it's crazy like a
camellia dark purples right they set him
down and then you see his little skin
start to change in the blood flow so
it's soaked and you see him you see them
in under the lamp under the layer yeah
like this chameleon anything and like
his skin changed and gets all pink like
a little shrimpy it's so it's crazy I
got dog this is not life
why [ __ ] dude nuts because the first
time I go there at the Hollywood press
appearing super ratchet like the whole
setup was ratchet the nurses were
[ __ ] ghetto [ __ ] the whole process
was just kind of second kind of I'll
dude and then when the the
anesthesiology gave her all the audience
before medication but when like they're
cutting her up and but Tiger Joe and
it's like shaken like like The Exorcist
and I go uh this can't be normal I think
oh well we can't give her medication
once the baby's out and I go yeah but
she's been shaking for five minutes man
she's like Oh shaking oh dude shaking
that you're pretty normal normal because
they they and she's still shaking cuz
cuz the anesthesia or that's what they
says he's actually a but that's what
they said and then this one I go hey
last time she she shook like don't like
bad looks like some Exorcist [ __ ] and he
started laughing I bet even happening
here didn't happen yeah no issues at
odds different profession now
professional professionals that's that
yeah my son the second time we were too
casual and my mom and my wife was just
kind of whatever hanging out and I was
like your casual you're popping little
you're hopping sure enough and I think
her water had already brought I can't
remember but she just goes all the
sudden I come back from the store and
her dad and her mom are there and she's
got both hands on the island in the
kitchens going huh and I go she's having
the baby now I think like a wool let's
get in the car I put her in my Prius my
red Prius my red I remember that thing
Barcelona red oh yeah and I start to
drive her and she goes I'm having the
baby in the car and I think her water
broke in the car so she goes I'm having
the baby here and I go alright so now
I'm kind of race
in my warriors can you don't want to
race with a pregnant woman who's having
the baby you don't want to do that
didn't produce you're fine because and
so I'm doing this I'm going take it easy
just breathe relax yeah so we get there
and because I'm having this baby I go
she's having the baby having a baby okay
Cedar sinai come out wheelchair they hit
her in the room yeah her on the toilet
she could screw the bathroom toilet
there's a woman she goes I'm at she was
and she was baby you can't have this you
can't have this baby on this toilet they
yank her off Oh miss 11% yes okay yes a
woman who's probably done it you know
again thousand gets her on the bed and
all and now man is not a week she's not
week she's Germanicus because she's
strong toe strong long legs so they
gotta hold her down and there's no end
there's no anesthesia she's having a
natural childbirth from the start I mean
she's a [ __ ] her legs like this
pushing she pushed that baby out and I'm
not exaggerating a did turds come a lot
of times Kurds come no comment but
that's what happens when a woman a lot
of times but she didn't have time for
any of that well you know that's the
thing like the kid gets into this world
[ __ ] slip inside Dookie all kinds of sac
that goes on
oh my so she she but she the baby came
out so [ __ ] fast that none of that
happened
because she just went oh my god but and
he shot the [ __ ] shot your phone shut
up 9000 podcast that's great he shot out
and I went on we didn't know if it's
Merrill girl or boy yeah I wish we
waited dude because when we cuz when we
were waiting while they're prepping Joe
all the her family my family's on the
waiting room and this I think they're
Armenian or Persian there's a lot so
pretty the win was so gorgeous and the
guys like super manly look yeah and
they're just waiting live like this and
then the Danny the nurses or no the
family the whole family was waiting the
room with us and then there you can see
they're just all like on pins and
needles and then dad comes back after
birth he goes we got a name he goes
Audriana
and they go it's a girl you ever thought
they won the goddamn that's cause a god
damn cool alright so when I saw my son's
ball sack I was I went
[ __ ] cuz I was I wanted a girl cuz I
thought they'd be easier of course boys
are wizard boy series here so now of
course it's like you know I got the best
of both worlds but it's crazy but they
do so so she we did no calculation from
the time I dropped her off and went to
park to the time the baby came out was I
believe seven minutes insane it's insane
she's my thing can you imagine Octomom
you're seeing bring a picture of Akhmim
her belly just drives belly was like
getting think she don't have fat on it
so it's like slow it's like as we type
there's Tiger and Boston they got bigger
look at her but Octomom hey wait look
you know maybe she had babies yeah or
ten eight eight and one go and then
she's all right a couple more before he
babies were in there dude eight [ __ ]
babies hold on let me see this she did a
porno to really know Obama no she did
not
I might have made that up I'm pretty
sure hi poor woman so in fact
how did that happen for she had any my
yeah yeah but and then went skipper to
eight babies a funny they all survived
yes
that's amazing look at all the babies
think how chaotic it would be cool when
they're like seven but think when the
earlier
are you serious those are all her babies
all her babies I heard a lot come on I
did bad enjoy is it a real Octomom porno
just to be I don't want thrown another
bus she didn't I'm almost policies in
shape now let me see the get two more
kids
she made some money off this obviously
yeah they did like there's all she had a
whole show damn look at her there that's
impressed her think about her something
L uncomfortable fact I mean I can't
imagine what you go through mentally and
physically they go through some oh no
there you go well no opens up out of her
porn path she's masturbating in it when
I click on the Octomom Nadya Suleman
opens up about her porn past yeah I know
my porno man she's not bad lot him had
some work as she went through she did
then then she decided to get pregnant um
that knows I've done bit most famous
moms I she gave birth to couples right
she was already seeing a parent to six
older children four sons
two dollars when she gave birth to eight
new dude she has 14 kids so if that
swimming was heavily criticized for
having too many children that she
couldn't afford and take care of aqua
mom says manager forced her into porn
fertility doctor lied to her a decade
later sumin who now goes by Natalie type
move his humble about her struggles to
raise 14 kids her regrets without doing
porn to make money well she did porn cuz
you need all those cool kids you gotta
do whatever you can that's 14 kids
that's crazy I would do it for my kids I
don't want them to be hungry I don't
know if I do porn no you're not making
that tons you know I couldn't provide
any more sedentary Australian show the
movies weren't coming as much like and I
couldn't work full-time at to mainland
kids keeps going down that's crazy
I didn't want to do any porn I've been
celibate for I came here all in the
years they're all beautiful so pleasure
video which is still oh she is just her
she's not in she's making railed who
privily came her manager for sin and
porn someone said she made $8,000 I sold
my soul to the devil $80,000 a jackoff
oh you know ever ate that nose and not
to it I mean I give a 10 to jack map
with a feet I don't I don't know you did
you just had a baby I'm gonna ask you to
take your right yeah well anyway I knew
she did poor but that's not really poor
that's like now she'd make more money
doing like those live can I tell you
she's from where yeah make Bank bro
uh-huh like Stevie's girl now makes way
more money doing their live [ __ ] look at
Octomom bro she's in some shame now dude
14 teeth that's impressive she works out
she's in shape that's impressive
good dude he'll be a bit of a badass
like come on I like this lady
a hundred percent oh yeah I like her
she's bad what's weird is the narrator
was just like oh she does porn so I was
like damn this Octomom been doing porn
there's a cutter I was jacking off dude
Wow dad working her body took off
[ __ ] beating let's be honest nuts
yeah she's pretty lady though man yeah
look at her tits look at that do you
know her stomach look like her stomach
you ever seen aliens yeah the
alien eggs Christ looks like I sell to a
crazy that she was able to carry all
those children how not the human bodies
in it's insane it's insane skin is so do
it they had to give my girl nepo dural
and that's the old you know yeah
epidural goes in the spinal I got the
spine is tricky if one if one one
centimeter to the left parallel so your
your spinal cord the actual cord is a
gelatinous substance it's like a it's
like as thin as your small finger it's
covered around all the bone
that's right you know it's yeah it's
covered by the bone yet but it's that's
the part that you cannot [ __ ] with you
don't want to give them that your spinal
fluid yeah great band what's that paint
me blue in this is that a ban heard it
sounds good dude
eight [ __ ] tap that's a spinal fluid
sounds like way cooler dude that's an
eight kids man
I want a squad so how about you know I
want I want like four kids but when they
they told my girly oh so you know when
we're in there we can tie your tubes
doesn't make sure there's no kids look
at the nursing that's what are you doing
yeah ain't no time to ask that I want to
see what money goes in case she said no
more kids come on you're Mexican
definitely more kids you know but I'm
gonna push the push the envelope I want
a little girl man you do right a little
girl with Octomom that's what I want to
do just kidding it'll girl dr. mom
Octomom does these days I might raise
kids and shut the [ __ ] up
yeah kids do twelve fourteen eight kids
man nuts yeah well she's she's on the
ground she's on that gram gram mm-hmm
think
dude I'm excited for the show nice ass
though daddy needs a break daddy right
father to needs a break
yeah little break oh I'm excited too
it'll be fun man much time we doing each
20 minutes so we got a ten o'clock show
ten o'clock show we got three people on
the force [ __ ] Brit isn't it great
mmm so up find out you're alright no big
deal but you're on it I mean no I want
you to host homie yeah hey guys it's
great to be here Brens merch in the back
Merson eyes Brendan Schaub hurts
all right it's a ryokan Brian just
shouldn't broken-hearted how was last
night at this door so it tripling
couldn't be more packed couldn't be more
like Sam's gonna do another best crowd
Sam's gonna do this oh yes he's great it
was a great crowd birdie little birdie
told me you have to follow Joey Diaz and
I knew that before you're going on I
thought I thought about it and I was
gonna text you and I was like Oh Brian's
the only guy on that lineup you can
follow Joey do you probably that guy
right now with you the material doing
yeah cuz I've seen Joe's material and it
slaps debase he was he was destroying
I'm never the lights go dark yes no one
I'm never ever there's no another win
light whatever worried about following
just I've been doing it too long but no
last night I watched him in from the
back I was getting applause everything
and I was like this I was like this is
gonna be this is gonna be interesting
this this for a second I was like this
might be nervous a child no never get
nervous because I just know even though
she you know yeah 90th but it was
interesting but then it was great there
were an amazing crowd there one of the
best crowds I've had that's what the
best sets I've had you know I want I was
supposed to be original was on it and
then Sam goes thing and make it my kid
comes the day I want to do it it's just
yeah yeah you gotta say how matter
respect but but a part of a part of it
was I'm high-energy and I have my pickle
for chess but it was they were [ __ ]
great what a great crowd yeah it was a
good show we did you watch - I never
watched from sight no matter who it is I
don't want to even fighting like I think
I don't like the the TV on over the
freights previous because if a guy gets
super [ __ ] up not like God everywhere
that's different want that in your head
but I sorta went ahead if the guy before
me he's eating [ __ ] bombing yeah and
then you go like I said I don't do my
thing you do your thing regard yes what
do you think regard I was never able to
really watch stuff Davidoff because I
loved his rhythm so much his rhythm was
so jazz like and different that I would
get caught sometimes in that zoo Sergey
yeah and it didn't work for me yeah you
know I'd be like I'd be doing some [ __ ]
well when you guys when we do life on
the kids are you I always remember
before you a lot of energy last yes yes
yes it slaughter with energy yes they're
all to know especially in the beginning
yeah first starting up you you hit him
with everything you've got
you don't give them you don't give them
time the huge part of like performance
is about domination like it sounds weird
but a huge part of performance is coming
out and saying this is how it goes
[ __ ] your lines you're about to
listen to this me lying to him yeah you
were listening to what that classical
that's adorable time time to turn this
down of a punk rock and [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] you my mouth ready but that is a
huge part of it domination of the
audience art is domination I've heard
that started up dude but The Comedy
Store because this podcast thing and
it's become a global market the Comedy
Store is so packed every day seven days
a week
it was always Sam Tripoli and I were
talking about the old days when the
counter was love a dark Hall with 12
people in the original room I [ __ ]
Friday you know it's weird though it's
and uh so I can endure kind of song
about this who were door guys at the
chemist or Dracula but the thing is is
um the the because the improv is great
place to but every top podcasts which
economy podcasts everybody talks about
The Comedy Store yeah everyone talks
about dockside so it's like created this
persona now we're all famous yeah I was
like well there's great lineups
about the same lineup there's nowhere
that he hits the same lamp economy store
but there's great lineups at the improv
some nights the factory is great layouts
but by SAS is great laughs but it's just
not like the comics cuz all the top
comedians and podcasters talk about that
referenced economy stores
TV shows comedy stories just and Missy
sure never really actually got to see it
dealers not not the way it is now she
never got to see it become this massive
tourist attraction because there was a
time when I had heard that they were
actually thinking about selling the
entire property modes yeah if they
wanted to they could have gotten twenty
five fifty dollars because they build a
hotel on that
oh dude and the shrine Oh make sure
their credit was like Matt or a [ __ ]
comedy primetime location there it is
Eric Griffin I hung with him last night
he's so
honey he's greatness he's great Oh
Whitney until I saw Whitney I [ __ ]
love with me she's so awesome
sheep shooting podcasts crushing it
great podcast your own good podcast
Whitney on their own podcast I heard
think it's called she videotaped me
without even realizing that I was being
videotaped lesson good for you good for
you yes good for you
I like that good for you good for you
I'm sentenced I'll do today hey Bryant
tomorrow's Thanksgiving can i stuff this
dick in there switch gears up hey hey
what was that
why'd you ask me damn it's Thanksgiving
don't be don't be selfish it's time to
give yeah and I'm gonna give you
something I'm gonna stuff these nuts in
your I don't want your nuts in my ass I
don't know how you do Thanksgiving you
have to hold me down a really promise
your little balls deep yeah I've heard
that that would be your dick and then
your balls are banging against my rump
or um / I'm already robbed within your
balls might be slapping my boss cuz you
know my balls so that would wear that -
you're having club without like yup and
your ball to be going down so they'd be
and we'd be both in pain gone ah my
balls and my [ __ ] and you know like
ow my balls that'd be such a problem I
took it there man I just timeouts
Thanksgiving you're the one who said and
all this stuff this dick in your hats in
them at your ball now it's like a bobble
this dick in your mouth
oh I'm that's not that's not the kind of
Thanksgiving I'm looking for I bro I
don't know what you're into how long in
the turkey but I'm not in today I'm not
into your big old mature predict and
introduction my innards
you don't want to duck in it turned out
can put go to Whitney Cummings up miss
story and this is I didn't know that I
was being [ __ ] videotaped but this is
what she videotapes me when I don't know
what's going on she [ __ ] with me yeah
keep going
I did guys behind me look at this town
oh she she's always in like your
massages huh
was it nice amazed 'yes great she's
amazing she always offers it now he's
turned it down dude she's the best
masseuse I've ever been I've never
what's your name um [ __ ] its gets tied
to edge on the smile of the best though
I can't believe I've casted I wanted to
know it's called happy ending that's
crazy yeah we're you getting massage
discipline yeah and I got to do it I
keep telling I'm gonna do a podcast
which I will [ __ ] how do I not joke
it's gonna be worse massage yeah you
want happy massage I'll let you know
where massage cast is that right yeah
she's great she's a great girl is that
it yeah joy him yeah joy joy that's
right cool she's so sorry joy she's so
nice she's always in there she's the
best at what I always past I was
thinking I'm good on this massage right
go out my neighbor is so funny my
neighbor is one of those guys who um
he's a he's a physical therapist but he
also has a dog that can do every trick
in the world and I don't and he was that
he was a horse trainer before that for
15 years so his dog now is one this like
it was wins these sort of nationally
come over he's like Sparky's yeah jump
it's always oddities but he's also a guy
who he's also do you talk about a
hustler yeah I go I go where were you in
he's I was just coming back from I was I
was dressed as he had an elf costume as
in his car I go what is having those who
is the elf there's an elf there's a type
of alpha girls now what type of elf he's
an elf that's in a movie
some kind of an elf and he goes it's a
specific elf from Disney and I he goes I
go what were you doing he goes I did
silly
singing telegrams I've been singing for
15 years so he it makes Johnny yeah he
sets him everything dude
he is not married he is by himself he is
he's got his dog now hold on nah I'm
just spitballing I visit let's just go
through what we know for you say plumber
right
no he's physical therapy okay physical
therapist his dog knows 1000 tricks
yeah and then he part times as a
caroling scene el you say he's their
singing telegram he dressed up as an
Alfie doesn't he does Elvis he does the
Snowman from frozen that's all of it I
guess so yeah so he had cool nicest
human being I have ever met in my
[ __ ] life so there I'm not saying
he's like this but that's what they said
about John Wayne Gacy I have neighbors
had no idea
then he dressed up as a clown they're
like yeah what he was fantastic bodies
in the basement and he feed what else is
weird tell your remains to his dog well
what else is weird is his dog know a
bunch of tricks I didn't know I did not
again to her brother Tom say it's
interest again to it huh
I'm have to check his he does live yeah
they're saying look into it dude mmm
maybe it is that time to give it's the
time to give and you and I shot a
Thanksgiving the time to giver it's just
time to give thanks and then Christmas
is the time yeah I don't you [ __ ] about
Thanksgiving to be honest but it did you
know I don't need a holiday it's time to
give but Sam Adams forced me to thank
you well don't force me gave me a reason
a commercial happy birthday that we're
gonna hear it now you want to hear it
cherry now yeah hit it I'll tell you do
it actual now we go all right here dummy
second I remember that Brennan and I
were we were so let me yeah so they
asked I think so
they asked Whitney Cummings Tom Segura
jo koy Theo von in Ari Shaffir and
myself so it's six comics they're doing
this campaign of you know basically
saying thanks appreciates the people
that got you to where you got your
career and yeah I was lucky enough to be
part of this and it was funny as they
you know get on call for career
there you go so here's my idea man we we
just you know we don't know who would be
in your career you know to to give
thanks to where you're at now you're
Albright County well you know most
people take three days in three or four
days the thing bragging I don't need to
is break out he goes oh okay you sure
know yeah dude I don't need a creative
ik it's Brian counties it's for my
career it's Brian counties all right
well that makes it easier okay cool but
I was thinking when I got the phone I
you know I'd been funny if I were toast
Dana White can we do another spoof and I
toasted Dana White that's funny as you
think you'd be into it I uh I don't know
I was getting like dude hit up dance if
he's dancing and doing this commercial
with me that'd be hilarious let
everybody know what toast you for sign
that Reebok deal and being making me mad
just being mean to me cuz put the
biggest chip on my shoulder
yeah and that's where I'm at man yes I
have no animosity towards them at all
but now I would help the UFC however I
can you know yeah but they've been funny
huh even if it's huge it would be got a
link to what day we're like we don't
want any sort of joke stuff like that
but it's a very good commercial all
right hit it being a comedian is the
greatest my basement on earth real
basements difficult job check out the
locks like ice to fight grown man in
this steel cage of my underwear
this is a great commercial with Sam
Adams to think legacy the foundation of
what America is about
the idea that Oh someone is important
because with so much content these days
in social media there's so much
negativity it's very rare where you stop
and actually make not showing that who
actually matters she's not through a
tweet I'll throw a picture on Instagram
it's important to do something like this
we know how everybody's movie ends
especially when it comes to boxers or
fighters you stick around long enough
everybody ends up face down but up on
the canvas there's no longevity in it
I'm on this rocky sea and it's foggy and
I don't know where I'm going I'm lost
and Brian Collins my lighthouse so you
would remind me that there's more to
life than fighting
and I was getting ready to spar this
giant guy they would give him five
hundred dollars if he knocked me out and
so he's this killer and he walks in this
gym and I start making fun of him not
mean but just kind of roasting what he's
wearing and how big he is and Brian goes
you know you need to stand up right I
was like yeah you're crazy but Brian
just kept planting that seed that meant
the world to me the world well no one's
worse at smelling the Roses than the two
of us stop and smell the roses the worst
I never do but I wanted to stop and take
a moment man and cheers you because you
saw something me that I even see in
myself and since day one you've pushed
me to get better and better as a
stand-up comic and try not to laugh but
also look at 110 years old there's like
a fossil Oh like everybody needs a
friend like you
7,000 years oh oh sorry is Britney
toasting on mommy and that extra zipper
this well do you feel it buttons are not
enough or is this a feature it's just
kind of wood oh it just makes me angry
when you're that fashionable for some
reason let's go enjoy your beer Boston
lager
that's a great camera great that tape
and I love it they said they said the
owners of Sam Ann's this campaign cried
during two people's commercials Joe
Khoisan this one yeah little [ __ ]
mercy lighting the lighting dude whoa
collect that freeze frame on my face
crazy issue you don't look like that I
think it's just the light I guess that's
now my dad 79 I don't think I think he
looks better
we're jealous I mean look at the [ __ ]
cheeks in the eyes
that's a disaster you don't really like
no but I look every bit of 6565 is like
77 years you said I was gonna be 76
years old tomorrow you I'd go he looks
cool I don't know you're right man but
that can mean been through some [ __ ]
well I mean talk about [ __ ] weathered
that's a beautiful commercial thank you
yeah that's have a beautiful card this
is easy one
Wow all minute ah Bryan Callen God you
look great on camera Jesus Christ no
makeup bro I couldn't be happier with
his hair like that it is getting you
look great without hair thanks dude
I don't look good you look great he's
going over there hey how often my face
looks like a barrel of snakes
so definitely face looks like a barrel
of snakes my Facebook's their old spots
for the bills Nate just a bunch of
Harold baked it so dirty I a bribe can
we tie his face back to school his face
is falling off his skull you know it was
uh do either the worst that same thing
oh man it was awkward a moon we got our
we have everywhere to do it and if you
keep English all right fellas kind of
tighten it up [ __ ] around the old
thing well I was beautiful I was worried
cuz uh Craig I think I was I don't know
if like the last one to shoot or
whatever but I was like is everybody
else is like funny cuz this ain't funny
man there's like the question they're
asking are like this this ain't that
funny La Crosse if you're looking for
funny man
we need to reshoot that's a beautiful no
it's not I don't they want to go we
don't want funny because it's a you
caught it you come across that's a
really good commercial I love it I got a
I'm gonna send that to my parents yeah
them too because they'll they'll love
that
yeah they wanted to beaut I'll find the
kid and then they're gonna post it great
Sam Adams next week they aired it during
the Boston Bruins game is this Matsumoto
a level 8
is it sponsored by Louisville a from my
face for youth creep wow man that's a
that's beautiful you what school all not
cool they're gonna send me the footage
but they had a bunch of footage of tiger
named tiger run around and rest
at death meet him when I get home I mean
it's on meaning my wrestling said all
this footage and he does man we if such
a different commercial with Tiger as a
fun commercial but because it's alcohol
they we can't help a with it I was like
Oh put up core kind of a perfect murder
I loved it
now who else who did thank who else
thanked who Whitney thanked her
assistant slash like producer I think
for a podcast cool jo koy I think this
mom go to joy coach go to Sam Adams
comer it might be Sam Adams it's already
I thought you joke I posted it on his
page ready today but if you're Sam out
he posted today
what is it threaded I know I know I'm
the last one to pull her this first
popped up I'm gonna post right now I
haven't seen this but I heard have yet
seen Jose I saw this is it that's it
they simply cried at mine and others
they credit mine because they're afraid
you were gonna die any second I'm gonna
post a [ __ ] commercial on my
Instagram that's beautiful
let's see this one else's I'm Jo koy
stand-up comedian and I'm here to toast
my mother and he's the nicest Denver and
none of this would have happened since
day one I wanted to make sure that the
world could laugh you're doing great and
then probably you wanted me to be a
lawyer
well we digress Sam Adams it's
grassroots it's family and that's why
Sam Adams is the best beer for this
toast the reason why I brought you here
today is I wanted to toast you this is
hard harder than I thought thank you for
everything you sacrificed
[Music]
so this is for you damn Joe and I toast
you and I love you so much thank you I
love you nappy - oh my god bottoms up
slow down ladies slow down lady I love
you geez man you want some more great
yeah uh who else is there
I'm telling if you go to Sam Adams they
have all of them up except for maybe
mine and Tom's me and Tom are the last
ones to post Samuel Adams there it is
are you over 21 yes [ __ ]
toast someone it's really good
commercial man I don't they cool jeez
then there's wait there's re bread ban I
don't know him and we're so close
there's Theo there's Jo koy and then Oh
mine's up now but then what they want
sprout they want me to post it next week
this okay so so so they we can't see the
ones that are not yeah you can see all
those let you see let's eat so Tom's is
the last one they go I think he posted
it yesterday though I saw it they just
once spread it out but why won't you do
it for things who did who Tom thanked
his wife Kristina oh I won't see is it
fine oh it's funny because I know it was
give me funny twittery sinner man Jesus
Christ she's so much better than ours
great oh dude have you seen Tom we'll go
to after this but Tom's dancing thank
you to me the idea of toasting someone
is exciting I love the idea of toasting
someone and saying that a lot of what I
get credit for is because of you
Sandman was for me reminds me of friends
and family
it's the perfect beer to tow somebody
with I've chosen the toast my wife I
could think of nobody more deserving to
be toasted I have nothing but amazing
things in my life - beautiful boy
they're [ __ ] great these they're all
of it is directly tied to having you by
my side and how hard you work so that we
can have my stuff I [ __ ] love those
twos - oh thank you I love you I love
you I can't wait we've been together for
so long I know it's time to move on but
for the time those are my neighbor
22-year old darling
those are my neighbors our kids are
similar age that's amazing
uh go - let me see Ari's
[Music]
to being a comic is the best I don't
know I may have people talk about how
hard it is right now but it's not a lot
of comments talking about like leave us
alone it's just jokes like no they're
not just jokes they're important
powerful words and we get to hit people
with them all the time when you came to
me and said hey Sam Adams says is there
anybody you want to toast your life said
goddamn right there is what better way
than a toast to share beer and you say
hey no more sips until we all agree this
next step is for this thing and so I
thought let's all have a sip for Brian
Redman so if I'm gonna make a toast
absolutely Sam Adams is a great beer for
that when I was maybe five years in I
mean I was scraping by at the time the
only way comedians could like get it
impressed
that's morning radio did it sucked we
always dream about like we had a radio
show but there was no outlet for that
and then Brian's good-looking guy
starters he finds a smart buy you got it
yes nope I can't believe you can't get
one Brian Redman we call him the pot
father and he's the pot father because
he got all these podcasts started read
back him to me and he was like let's
start podcast let's do one and I try to
fight him up for a while because I was
always real addicted to my failures you
know yes
addicted to my family he got me to do a
podcast and it just or taking off I got
listeners I got followers I've developed
a fanbase because I've reached out on
that podcast and I couldn't have done it
without this dude Brian Redman that's
amazing
yes that's a great one to [ __ ] know
where I was nine years ago before you
forced me to do a podcast I mean I was
doing nothing with my career yeah you
were I mean a little I was working hard
on stage but I was a loser like career
was I have a way to reach my fan base
now I can make a living as a comic mark
morning radio no more morning radio you
make your own schedule and you help
yourself out you owe me a lot of money I
was starving I do owe you a lot of money
you owe me a lot of money one of the
cheapest comedians in the world I can
never repay you financially but what I
can do is to give you a Sam Adams and I
want to toast you because honestly the
toast I want is to recognize them and if
anybody needs recognition its you thank
you for all the love I love Ari - Ari
such an honor dude brother it's such a
phenomenal comic man God they're both
just greatness it's great to see that
[ __ ] let's be able to see this [ __ ] in
it cool man
yes music - whoever chose this music
this is me playing being Theo von I kind
of wild right now life's gotten pretty
crazy it just kind of blows my mind
sometimes I have an opportunity to toast
anyone that I want I'm gonna toast the
audience that comes to my shows this
next guy is one of my favorite people in
the whole world to watch you're very
very lucky I don't drink alcohol but I
wanted to be part of this campaign
because toasting is such a simple act of
kindness letting somebody know that you
recognize them letting somebody know
that they mean something to you thank
you dude a lot of recognition these days
is liking something or sharing something
it's just so fleeting the value of that
but on the breaks let somebody know they
mean something to you
I realized the other day I look like
somebody who knows where the rabies and
Sam Adams is the permit for a toast as a
traditional vibe to it
turn about reincarnation bro you know
cuz I'm planning on doing it again you
know these fantasy qualifing I feel like
we get advertising one thing that
delivered something else people deserve
to get something for their money when I
see a couple sitting there maybe they
hired a babysitter and this is their one
night of the month that they go out and
do something fun a mother and son that
will come out to the show or a pair of
brothers I want to make a toast actually
to you guys you guys always continue to
come back and allow me to really follow
my dream you know like this is my dream
for years how we get to the venue and
there wouldn't be anybody there that's
why it's important to me to put on the
best show you know I couldn't live my
dream if there weren't an audience so I
want to toast you guys the audience for
always being there for me and meeting me
in every city that I go to anybody can
be toasted it's something we need more
of telling each other
I see you and thank you if your next
beer is the same Adams tonight it's on
me everybody in the house and I thank
you very much from the bottom of my it's
cool Matthews
yeah what's Eastern right yeah isn't a
great campaign yeah he was uh he was
worried about doing the commercial
because you know he's sober so you know
for a while now so he associated with
bamileke but do it as a comic man you
know I think it shows strength about
Kamala tree but you can be around it and
still do your job and like hang out with
us when he because he was in Pittsburgh
same time I was in Pittsburgh came The
Late Show I get are you pretty [ __ ] up
not that [ __ ] up but I'm pretty tips
I've I've fun it's a good environment or
fun so he came back he was like oh dude
he's like whisk him like yeah dude
that's what I do man this what the [ __ ]
I do like I go out to have a great time
he's like oh wow well you're you're
you're such a disciplined control guy
that you never will ever be in danger on
having alcohol get in the way of any oh
it's some people can't turn it off yeah
and so that's where it becomes a oh
you're a little drunk now but anyway the
things I thought I do have a little
Bailey's you know and that's okay but
dude it's a but you know what it's 11
we're fine
I talked the other I think shows
strengthen shows people that do have
like alcohol issues I've been around it
is it's like you can still be in the
environment be of the discipline not to
[ __ ] with it I think as I was watching I
remember I've known Theo I guess now god
I'm going back to the the west side
brewing day people forget how long he's
been doing it man I've known Theo I've
been watching Theo to stand up he's been
around for at least 15 he's been touring
for 14 okay so the guy the guy who shot
this camera well to go created this so
Sam Adams right hired someone to do this
the guy's the they hired a guy to do
this guy named Kevin hmm I didn't know
this but you know Kevin's a big comedy
fan you know his comedies a brilliant
guy him his brother the ones you met him
mm-hmm I like him his brother down the
production company but we're time out
Theo and he goes oh yeah I mean Theo's
one my close friends there what he was
yeah I've known Thiel for 15 you sleep
on my couch and why me until know each
other very well and you know but why so
I'm doing stand-up I was thinking about
how where he's come from and and he goes
it's so crazy because you
at this time but for the longest time
Theo out offstage is the funniest person
I've ever been like he would at dinners
like the finest person ever but he could
never he's always trying to be someone
else on stage right so it never really
worked so then not that didn't work he'd
still but he wasn't selling any take it
sure for though I remember that at 14 14
years yeah and then finally he's like
his true self on stage and podcasting it
did it forget I mean know that then I
was so I was thinking about Theo was on
road rules or something like that how
long ago was that
I mean 90s so I don't do I I've
technically I might have known Theo
maybe 20 years now which is mind-blowing
because I've known him as a guy who was
on road rules and was doing a little bit
of stand-up and I never paid attention
right and then I saw him five years ago
maybe six years ago maybe five do
stand-up and I went hey dude you're
[ __ ] really good and he never thought
of himself that way right you know but
but it's just weird to see him now okay
so it took him 20 years to become
successful welcome to the world you know
so anybody out there who's young and was
yeah it took do 20 years to find who
really sure or whatever the case yeah
yeah 1995 was that when he was part of
it that's when I started okay I don't
know what season he was have you ever
seen the the the highlights of Theo on
there you would never make the show
because there's an agent on the casting
us listen I'll talk taejun's I don't
know what they're talking about like
it's it's funny it's Theo it's hilarious
because you know he's not ill yes being
dramatic yeah but it's they they would
never air Theo on MTV today yeah you can
finally you do feel YouTube's feel don't
watch it we can it's funny but yeah I'm
not sure you could eat you wouldn't make
any TV oh that's sweet Roy diaries drop
your fear of on first one
[Music]
like about the past month I've seen like
I'm in limbo kind of like I'm like I'm
between like lives kind of like part
ghost part human my father died a couple
years ago and then my mother actually
lives down in Tucson yeah he the age of
14
my mother emancipated me like legally
emancipated me like signing the contract
and everything that just says that I'm
responsible for my own actions and
whatnot I think I was kind of a special
kid growing up and out really
good-looking doing a lot of affection I
needed a lot of attention she couldn't
do it I mean it's gonna be hard on me in
the future I think is I don't really
know how to care about somebody clue
less so he was abandoned by his mom at
14 that's what it would be between 18
and 24 and I knew who's gonna be three
girls yeah yeah I got this dream much an
Asian guys just feels like Japanese
never met one I have a bigger I can't
deal with Asian people that I don't
think thank you never just had trouble
dealing with Theo he's 19 he's young he
probably hasn't been around a lot of
people of color what in the hell is Theo
that's what I think people think of me
when they first talk to me they don't
really understand me cuz I mean a lot of
times I don't even understand myself you
know I'm surprised as other people are
at some of the things that come to my
head or so the things that I think about
why do you do it why do you play about
it
well you're just good to me
works out it's about brotherhood and
camaraderie rugby doesn't care if you
get hurt and sprained ankles sure relax
what's where does he talk about B then
Carrie had her sprained ankle to keep
and he just heard that so he's a young
man in regards to but um interests this
says a lot about the ER there that's
that's he was abandoned by his mom and
he had himself to rely on only no one
else was there you never get over that
that's part of the reason he probably
goes through depression and doesn't
think he's as special as he really is
Wow remember when we did that show at
the Orpheum Theatre in Phoenix is you me
big J Ari Shaffir I sent a TX feel was
the last one yeah and all the stood
backstage and cuz he was like God before
he went I was like I'm gonna do this new
bid I don't know about doing it goes out
there and [ __ ] crush I was like man
is so good I said okay back in everyone
dude I mean it was it was incredible
yeah he's incredible he's a special man
he was a special [ __ ] dude he's shooting
a special I was talking with some comics
about this the other day there's there's
a few people are gonna shoot specials
you know how like when Nate bargatze did
it Segura cry sure when they get on
Netflix adjust see their careers go
Theo's gonna shoot his soon on you know
I think that flakes and Andrew Schultz
and both of those [ __ ] have
rocket packs and they're gonna be the
next to that go yes get tickets we can
no doubt some print event hey bro can I
ask you a question man sure dude your
legs your your backside your your rump
it looks like two turkeys well dude I
mean I gotta be honest with you you look
tight and in your whole body looks tight
what are you doing lifting weights just
kind of you running a lot yeah I do one
thing one thing only what's that man
well-documented if you've ever seen any
my Instagram stories and I shout from
the heavens I'm a peloton member dude
I'm part of the peloton squad I got that
bike that Paul talk about if I walk in
your house at 6:00 in the morning
there's a good chance I'm gonna hear you
you see on your peloton you see
I love going come on guys I'm like this
what does Halle love was that eyes my
trainer has it works my train let's
peloton work peloton works you have a
bike there's a giant screen on it
you have on-demand videos you get you
can do live videos you have a bunch of
different trainers to choose from
there's like a kind of gift that gift
for the holidays oh you do you want the
best gift the gift that keeps on giving
yeah the gift of fitness the gift of
community what if I get into my houses I
it's a bike and offs and I don't want it
kind of 30-day worry free trial that I
come glad you brought it up dude the
gift of a worry free trial and with
peloton Zoo 30-day home trial they can
try the bike worry free for 30 days if
you like you know what I don't want to
be shredded and be part of community and
be awesome and healthy and feel good
every day I'm gonna send it but I don't
want to do the same class over and over
again that gets boring you know I'm
saying I want Oh world-class instructors
and motivation I want I want
entertaining live and on-demand classes
that's all I'm asking for I don't want
the same thing dude
I do the 45 minute interval training I
do weights and bikes where I'm I'm
sprinting but then I'm on the weights
that's written I'm the weight I do the
30 minute hit training when I want a
nice in-and-out workout doing yeah
there's nothing better than peloton it's
the gift that saved time as well
with efficient high intensity cardio
like I just told you at the luxury of my
basement dude what I saved time I'm not
sitting in traffic I mean a nice workout
I'm burning up bunch of calories I'm
with friends my peloton friends okay for
the holidays dude I'm ready for this
I've been writing my peloton do they
keep track this forty two weeks in a row
bro whoa missed one in forty two win
true yeah that's no joke no jokes man I
got a hundred ride just stupid animal
ah well Frost for a stupid animal
holding family time here yeah your old
asses on it yeah tunes on it yeah cats
on it yeah you do that well is there any
kind of a holiday gift kind of promotion
that you could give me all right I
talked to peloton we're gonna do this
one time one time only it's all they
give the gift of peloton for a limited
time you get $100 off accessories they
have some pretty cool workout gear on
their shirts shorts hats by gear $100
off accessories when you purchase the
peloton bike go to
Pellatt on comm use the promo code the
fighter at checkout that's one Pelton
comm promo code fell fighter sure Oh
Matt you know what man people's
depression and sadness and stress levels
they go through the roof around the
holidays all about families and as you
need a professional like a professional
counseling service a real person quit
talking your buddy about your problems
get to somebody who can actually solve
and get down to the roots of your issue
and you don't want to be waiting in a
waiting room you don't want to spend the
kind of money you have to for a
one-on-ones also embarrassing right from
the luxury of your bedroom that better
held own better help them get you
communicating with a licensed
professional in under 24 hours there's a
broad range of expertise and better
helps counselor network which may not be
locally available in a lot of areas the
service is available for everybody
worldwide you can do it anytime you want
yeah enliven your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule scheduled weekly video
or phone sessions so you won't have to
sit in a waiting room plus you can even
chat and text with your therapist
between sessions yeah
so it really is good for a lot of TV and
I invite it it's fantastic to us unless
you don't have anybody to go to advice
for sometimes you just feel like you're
lost and that's it and here's the thing
they have financial aid that's even
available it's great man visit better
help calm slash fighter and join the
over 500,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional and UT fat k
listeners you get Timpson off your first
month at better help calm slash fighter
that's better help calm slash fighter
dude
Thanksgivings here but I don't care
about things if you know I care about
Black Friday Black is to Friday dude the
darkest blackest Friday
ever get is on it calm not it right now
is gonna drop the Black Friday on yo ass
and turn the world of fitness upside
down yeah oh yeah maybe if you've been
thinking about trying on it or maybe you
are and on it member you want
supplements I'm telling you man when
Black Friday comes get your mind right
get your money drop some sales go to
audit calm
get 10% off when you're on comm slash
fighter but wait for Black Friday cuz
everything you like is on sale crazy
sales they do the biggest sale you can
get on Black Friday Black Friday just
got a whole lot blacker a whole lot
black black in up you got digestive
health issues they got you you got sleep
issues they got you you got brain issues
they got you you got support and
vitality as you they got you essential
nutrients they got it performance you
want to workout at home on at 6:00 you
want to burn off the freakin pecan pie
or the pumpkin pie band stuff in your
stupid mouth with all holiday season do
it with on it six body weight workouts
that on demand training they got it all
battle ropes I don't know ropes sandbags
maces Indian clubs kettlebells door F
star slammed by prevention yoga mats
barbells vest ropes you said that
already
row pointers they got everything dude we
got ropes ropes hey can I put my robe on
your face nope but I throw ropes when it
comes to football or baseball all right
guys
audit dock cops last ride 10% off Black
Friday enjoy Quran events to stop a
Current Affair hounds the [ __ ] what got
onto to Jenny Tom's dance video no one
of the fan submitted current events you
so do you saw Bert's yes watch this
these [ __ ] changing the game
poor wife
here's a wife is definitely racist right
probably stinks - hey Tom Segura dancing
your whole life oh no you can actually
dance though where he's athletic
[Music]
you
machine but she watch me
you
[ __ ] you Bert oh my god
that's phenomenal that was crazy but I
was kidding you're my best friend and I
love you you see walk in there that's
actually good dancing he can dance how
fun is that
that's [ __ ] phenomenal those two men
kill him again tell me about it killing
the killing of Missy Elliott's throw it
back hilarious right and did you have to
buy the rights to throw it back
that's not worried about to look a mess
no not the rights but he has to get
permission for sure that looks expensive
that looks like an expensive production
oh yeah I mean - it's super high level
he hired a chorus she's I mean big big
yeah a guy who does music video
choreographer like everything that they
him and burnt have but they have a bit
dancing your whole life I know it's
brilliant what they're doing they have
budgets in their yearly business plans
for stuff like this that's genius how
many how many
it's got oh I don't know 13 a million a
million three hundred thousand point
four million views yesterday Wow
Jamie last week what thousand people
dislike that he was inspired by a sensei
Steven Seagal and his friend Bert
Kreischer let here's outcome from he
paid for all that yeah they beep it's
insane right it's beautiful okay here's
the other thing it's a promotion - for
his date yeah yeah almost all Murray
sold out it's brilliant what they're
doing yeah it's a big production hmm
cool right well smart and awesome yeah I
love him what else did guess one okay so
last year during 2019 there was a big
tour where they had a lot of RMB groups
that were popular in the early 2000s
reunite and they did a tour similar to
what the Backstreet Boys did with the
kids
new kids a lot the kids me okay they're
young and what happened was this past
year Omarion separated from his former
wife who is the mother of his children
and she started dating one of his
bandmates from b2k and after they did
the tour really and she and she went on
to say that his bandmate who was one of
his closest friends has the best dick
she's ever had and she's just on TV
they're doing this whole like Love & Hip
Hop storyline about how like she's in
love with his bandmate meanwhile they're
trying to do another tour and they're
trying to take it overseas what ended up
happening was Omarion stayed very quiet
about his bandmate now dating his
ex-wife and said you know what if she's
happy I'm happy but what he proceeded to
do was set up the second installation of
the millennium tour for 2020 that will
go overseas with all of these R&B bands
from the early 2000s he left out b2k and
he released it on the day of his former
bandmates birthday
mm-hmm and he is currently that's known
as the petty king you know that yeah
petty how was that little was a little
bow-wow he's a little remember no just
bow-wow I think yeah how about Cointreau
because remember he was he posted that
he was on a private jet and then of
things all Southwest was that going
through in scrims like private nope
click and it went so viral and you tried
to play it off like I'm doing this some
guys think I did that cuz when you fly
to Burbank it's you know it's a smaller
Airport so it looks like you're flying
private because you have to go you walk
to the plane there's this young black
kid behind me he's like okay what he's
on he's the one whoa whoa you know what
it is you know I walked into the jet
setter and he like plasters at the plane
just the back and like the stairs he's
gonna walk jet setter here you know how
we do
flying that private I wanna be like no
he's not we're on Delta Y and then
people will tag jet sweet X cuz it's
like a mile away
yeah yeah [ __ ]
but yeah Omarion is currently being
known as the petty king for doing this
dude how much money have you guys made
the petty the Ying Yang Twins Lloyd
Pretty Ricky and Soulja Boy mm-hmm
Jesus Christ a lot of people are doing
these type of tours on these throwback
tours
it's huge over oh it overseas apparently
Asia really loves all of these like that
old-school Xie age no way were fashion
to man Japan they on Jovie sells out and
[ __ ] Europe and one Joey sells ideas
over in Argentina yeah it's not here -
yeah but not the way not over there yeah
but same with like special slow movies
Brock over there like those action
movies right funny
so Papa John's didn't interview recently
saying that within the last 30 days he
ordered 40 pizzas from Papa John's ever
since he's been removed from the company
and he says that it got removed to drop
the n-word on a conference call and he
is saying that that was staged by people
within his team to try to get him out
and that the day of reckoning is coming
he's like setting up something that he's
sweating garlic bread yeah what's he
sweating well he's not doing well
clearly he had some work on his face I
actually have met him and he's got he
seems to be a weird dude like a very a
very hater he seems to be a very my you
know when I initially saw him he seems
to be very uptight he seems to be a
vessel he just seems to be a very kind
of anal guy like a very kind you should
get more anal with it's very stiff in
the body it's told we should get more
[ __ ] anal as pizzas Pizza sucks [ __ ]
wow those guys I'm gonna take a guess he
might be one of those guys who's very
very insecure and he made good with lots
of money he's a good businessman part of
that that sort of like a know a million
details a tail or anything but it
doesn't mean you're secure with yourself
it doesn't mean you don't have some kind
of an emotional hole there you don't
think Elon Musk is insecure yeah a lot
of these guys 10-degree what's driving
them is a deep insecurity
everybody yeah myth I mean yeah but some
some people it's pretty I've seen as I
get older I've seen some very successful
people that have everything on paper and
still feel like the kid in high school I
got picked on I don't know how I would
say it's 95% of people do of all peoples
who are yeah a lot of a lot of
successful a ton of them but this guy
has me sweating crazy bread as he's
doing City there's something wrong
during this interview yeah he's not
doing well yeah also it's pizza don't
say the [ __ ] reckoning it's coming
yeah you're slinging pizzas dude his
question yeah I've had over 40 pizzas in
the last 30 days Livi currently and Mark
Shapiro should be in jail he has no
pizza experience he's never been in the
pizza category I would just say stay
tuned the day of reckoning will come the
record will be straight why not set the
record straight now I mean what is it
about the record that's not straight
stay tuned
Jack Nicholson's Joker look at him dude
he's like I kind of like him now that's
not the guy I met so I take back
everything I said it just looks like a
tough guy there he's kinda like his
voice this guy he's just like uh he
looks crazy as [ __ ] well I think he's
just he had his company taken away from
him they put somebody in who doesn't
understand he's you know Papa John's
became big because obviously they were
doing something where people loved the
pizza this dude eats his own product
[ __ ] it I like that guy like ever
batshit crazy I think gets worse from
here he's gonna be the Lindsay Lohan of
pizza mate no he's [ __ ]
nobody he's a mad genius I think all
they're having a right there never you
enjoy a mad genius of making pizza have
you tried Papa John now I haven't they
say Papa [ __ ]
hey awful dude hey man right cuz he has
been in there a while Munoz
that's a [ __ ] you know I had a
Domino's Pizza and it was fin I was like
I was like whatever and it was some of
the best [ __ ] I've ever had a crust
fence I was like what are they put in
this you get extra sauce pepperoni oh it
is so good you get a Brooklyn style dude
fantastic they've got it down to a sun
table Jon's can't compete whether this
they're not hmm it doesn't end well for
him s'matter what else you got this here
okay so do you guys know what the
platform cameo is yeah he does like Bert
I give all the money to charity thank
you
so it was line me on there the lead
singer of Sugar Ray he is also on cameo
and he got paid $100 to make a video for
a girl on behalf of a girl trying to
break up with her long-distance
boyfriend and this went viral no I love
mark McGrath by the way you think it
really is fantastic that Braden it is
mark McGrath from the band sugaring off
the charts but always in your hearts and
this cameo was booked by Cheyenne and
she wants you tell a few things and I
can't believe it a little difficult for
me to say it cuz it's the first one of
these I've done did imagine sugar rain
breaking up with you that you mean a lot
to her you mean the world to her but
she's having difficulty staying in this
long-distance relationship you know it's
tough I've been on the road for years
and I've been with my wife a long time
and the biggest arguments the biggest
you know obstacles in our relationships
is the distance between us it makes it
very difficult when around the road how
long does cameos supposed to be there I
do him for three minutes it's very very
tough for her to stay in this
relationship she still cares about you a
lot
you never know what the future may hold
and she still wants to be friends with
you because obviously she cares about
you very he's good there's a good way to
break up she's nice good I think it's
terrible this is coming up a buck timing
Cheyenne unless you're 45 like well who
the [ __ ] is this gunner stand you know
you gotta work on your thesis and life
goes on and in college no I'm sure
there's big things ahead of you in the
future Braden but Cheyenne cares about
you enough to let you know that she's
thinking about you but the long-distance
thing is just a little difficult for her
and by the way now it's out there for
everybody did he put it out there who
the guy who got the cameo because
everybody can see this everybody can see
your cameos
I'm sure lessee mark was so nice about
it huh
so nice he was trying his best it's a
good thing I do plot this podcast
because I'm getting to an age where I
wouldn't know anything about anything
would I you know what I mean like you
got to be on that yeah you saw the video
somebody who saw seven there were two
there were two famous rappers in the
green room last night I did not they
were so nice and I did not know they
were sure don't but someone's like I
grew up listening to you bro and he's
like ah thanks they were smoking copious
amounts of food good guys that's broken
up with so this is another [ __ ] I have
to tell you this I got broken up like
this I was in when I was um when I was
doing it was when I was doing Sex in the
City
and I was I really like this girl her
name was brie I really liked her and and
I was doing I was in New York and I just
she was just like [ __ ] but she was I
don't know she was so beautiful
I met her doing a reading and I couldn't
believe she liked me and I'm doing the
damn thing I'm on set for two weeks Sex
in the City New York City and she's on
yeah and I and I got everything planned
cuz she's gonna come when I'm done
cheating I got a whole weekend planned I
got a whole [ __ ] weekend tell you I
got tickets to like different Broadway
shows I got four I got [ __ ] awesome
reservations at the best restaurants I
got a even think I bought some clothes
I'm like this is gonna be a sick weekend
cuz this is gonna be the weekend or
she's in New York she's gonna see my
friends near but I'm dating her like
this gonna be my girlfriend yeah I was
so pumped that was telling my friends
about her storm pictures and and I go I
go hey I go up so I'm gonna get you at a
case is on the phone I'm gonna fire
first class I don't have money I don't
have money I was gonna fire first class
I go I'm gonna fly you out and she was
can I could just call you back really
quickly I go okay so I go yeah yeah
we're in LA and she goes hey so I'm I'm
not gonna come in New York I go huh
and she goes oh yeah I don't want to do
this anymore
oh yeah I go I go I go
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry it's just not
there for me I guess she had met this
lawyer who was six foot six and who was
awesome and whatever it was it was but I
mean she my Jimmy Burke was there
Jimmy heard it laughs Jimmy heard it and
I was like okay well you know I
understand I guess thank you
you know look I liked you it felt good
to like somebody and all right he broke
up with me not so hard yeah and Jimmy
I turned to Jimmy and Jimmy Burke is
looking at me and he's doing this he's
going like this he's got his [ __ ]
lower lip out like a baby's born mmm any
minute he was I'm sorry Bubba that was
tough I go and it is what it is I was so
long I was Barbara and I was [ __ ] by
I told you the time I hurt my feelings I
was down I did this girl forever in high
school and I finally had to break up
whether my dad goes and we she was like
so sensitive and she'd cry over
everything I told you my dad goes we to
make it easier on yourself I would do in
a public place because then she doesn't
feel like I'm crazy
and so I took her to PF Changs in Park
Park Meadows to get a PF Changs and
we're sitting there and I was this like
waiting and she's like yeah all right my
camp good and I was like I'm gonna order
and then before the food comes I'm gonna
do it that's my plan
and we're like you know just small talk
now yo hey listen I know like we've been
together for a while it's just not what
we're both going to call it this isn't
working and it's perfect man and she
goes what she goes white loudly whoo oh
no she goes
scuse me shows you're doing this here
I'm like around like no well yeah I mean
within she gets tears I go yeah so
embrace the way to come to you bails you
bail though I'm not we're not breaking I
was just saying we should talk about the
I stayed with her for another 60 damn
right you do you're damn right I go
darling
[ __ ] Terry wife for six months than
the face that guy that's crazy
she's like what
oh no I'm not kostik wrath sticker
I'm saying I'm John it back what was six
months we've all done that but if you've
been broken up with oh yeah yeah that
was such a that was tough cuz I really
liked her and I had like plans I was
like I'm gonna date this girl yeah I
liked it and I thought it was good the
sex everything I thought I thought was
good all of it was good
could she laughter it was a perfect
relationship she wasn't she was she was
she was new gosh exact you young too but
the thing I was yeah yeah well yeah I
remember in high school my coach coach
Weaver receivers code she was the best
call everyone slap dicks he's an older
coach and I had this serious girlfriend
and we were holding hands you know going
off to college and we're holding hands
and she's all like crying you know cuz
the end of the year a shot let me talk
to you real quick he goes state your
name stacy is go over there it's never
talked to us stop it stop it quit being
a slap dick here's what's gonna happen
this your girlfriend high school usually
go to college you can [ __ ] a bunch of
people get over it
don't make it all sad around the
hallways and [ __ ] you so right oh man
yeah you don't feel deeply when you're
young you feel [ __ ] what you think what
he does you don't you do have no
perspective perspective he's like hey
this is it this isn't one slap dick yeah
this is a heartbreak when you're young
though cuz I when I was reading my head
like insight and [ __ ] my girlfriend
broke up with me when I was 18 and I was
in college and I realized it was over
and she was at Wesleyan and I was in
shift so she was in Connecticut I was in
DC and I realized it was really over
your boy cried alone outside because I
couldn't cry my dorm that roommate you
boy cry
so hard that I thought I was gonna die I
remember looking up at the [ __ ] moon
its way to lying down crying oh you're
harder literally your heart Oh John you
have heart disease I mean I really go
weeping are we going breakup stories oh
all [ __ ] on yours or some of that girl
that I try breaking up with at PF Changs
and we started working [ __ ] out so I'm
sure we'll probably get married and then
you know I'm don't have much money I'm
going door-to-door sales like pursuit of
happiness I'm living with
J at the time we have like this place
she's living there too and I go to do I
know something was up we were a little
off I go to do Golden Gloves the boxing
tournament and it's over three days so I
passed the first round Gillis second
round she didn't come the first round go
set ground every way there shouldn't
come second round finals it's a big on
the camera in the finals I'm like a
where you actually Oh we'll figure out
finals I win I'm with I'm never gets on
with clop we're driving home I get I'm
like God the house looks dark I walk in
everything's gone furniture TV
everything she wait for the right
opportunity to pack up all this [ __ ] I
don't have any money what were the
finals or stuff going glass box off
going clothes boxing she packed up
everything she took everything
everything including our dog moved out
never heard from it's it's I don't have
anything what adding when I had to do an
eviction same girl though or no
different the PF Changs go what she
broke up with me she had a plan that's
crazy
wow she took all our [ __ ] TV it
everything had nothing that's a good
time she left my brother had his room so
she left his [ __ ] alone but all those
stuff was I cursed she had rich rich
parents so they bought us all stuff but
she she knew I was gonna be gone for
whatever
four hours of this boxing tournament she
got all truck every move all [ __ ] out my
girl when I broke up with her she took
all her furniture because she had
furnished our house antennas so she took
all of it including the bed I was still
sleeping Elia and the she goes we have
to get the bed and I go I'm still
sleeping she goes well we need the bed
that turned into a major fight and she
opened the windows and start screaming
stop hitting me she said stop hitting me
stop hitting me screaming and then the
neighbors I want to run everything I
don't hit my girl they go we know we did
we don't we know you don't we knew we
knew that was [ __ ] I remember not
having to still gave all the couches
American American Furniture Warehouse in
Denver sure and looking at couches and
one was $300 I couldn't afford it there
you go
that was a bummer three hugs get on for
300 our couch yeah tough gig that's
that's what happens when you're young
and chasing your dream you spent a lot
of time
with no money well what else you got
well another fan submitted stories that
they want to see you guys react to this
f-150 vs. the Tesla truck mm-hmm and
it's the Tesla truck pulling f-150 how
is that I'm sorry to ask is that Tesla
truck an open bed there no okay
this close bed I think I can't it opens
and closes oh well it opens but it's not
an open bed lycée say if that like I
can't like throw something in it from
here right is it closed the look sighs
close there
ya think it's closed because it opens ah
I love it they said I'll buy one for
sure
well here's the problem with this I
don't need to see any comments so first
of all that's not a four-wheel-drive
f-150 it's a rear-wheel drive f-150 the
front tires aren't moving
so it's JC just pulling a truck with no
payload and up a hill and also got you
did they get buck - right what I also
got the jump on the truck because it's
electric it was going first yeah yeah
it's very strange
what's what's Neil deGrasse Tyson say
about it bad ass testimony through
embarrassing but if the f-150 is
rear-wheel drive with no there you go no
payload the weight on the rear axle is
greatly reduced offering only mild trash
from a Tesla to overcome this kind of
s'more about physics of friction than
engine power cry
is it nice yeah how there's no load in
the back and it's that two-wheel drive
f150 the engines in the front so that
back is gonna be so light oh I say yeah
oh I see so okay it's nothing that you
know like your kids grow when you pull
back you buddy how did you know it was a
form was not a four-wheel drive I'm
looking I'm like the tires moving the
front ones weren't moving it you know
like though they should right that's not
it was from Kalin yes okay from Kalin
[ __ ] yeah that's weird I was gonna
say it's [ __ ] what do I know
all right um this is just an update on
your that guy that you're talking about
before that you knew Brian Harry Morton
so he died from a heart attack block
Carter's no way yeah see I told you I
never knew him to do drugs yeah so that
was just a bad assumption on my part it
stopping here you checked out by the
doctor but that's that's a pretty
preventable thing too and a lot of
people die from it 38 years old yeah
there's one artery
yeah just heart issues everyone just go
to the doctor a nurse check you gotta
get you got to get yeah you got to get
out you can get a 3d 3d sort of a look
at your heart I mean they look at
everything thanks for that I do where
the blockage is I might do that Yeah
right on
you know 3d thingy well now I gotta get
my face checked out - I have to get
I'd get the [ __ ] I don't know it you
know may if I may have amnesia because
that might be lying to you yeah this one
here you talked about a little bit
are you sure hosts perineum sunny dude
how about people suntan there [ __ ]
I've seen this i'ma do this here's my
spin around I don't know I've seen some
[ __ ] in my lifetime right just so
happens mainly chicks mainly senior
[ __ ] more chicks I'd say four to one
guys the girls acyl sure but whatever
everybody's [ __ ] pretty tan there's
no reason to get it son no no that's
like so the reasons everyone ringing is
pretty dark you're supposed to it
apparently raises your hormone levels
your testosterone and it's all the
benefits you get from Sun but it's just
faster they said 30 seconds on your ass
horse we have any evidence of this I
mean I would I would just spread my
cheeks go outside on my back to call bro
science corporate pseudoscience is there
any way the math I think she's the one
that that became famous for it and then
this became a thing he imagine seeing
someone's [ __ ] starfish in your grill
yeah dude everyone's starfish is pretty
dark too
have you ever seen like a pale one no no
you can bleach your anus people do that
yeah girls bleach
let's see some bleached anuses what
bring them up no that's a notorious and
porn you kind of have to bleach your
Bobo gayness just can't have it all dark
I think so yeah I think it's just like
an aesthetic thing I'm sure gay gay guys
do it too right I don't know relaxed
yeah well that's different I would too
bleached anus you know bleaching God
just images you want I don't want to
course I know there's there's usually a
black ring in it but then again she's
she's um thick you lady I know she's got
a can I get a before and after I would
assume that burned your [ __ ] I don't
know I'm a fan that's a great piece
going talking right before and after
damn because you don't want to and
they're not showing the anuses chicken
do you have a do you have a bleached
anus if you're a girl I yeah it makes
sense to do it
mmm there's that those are adorable
little rump holes well button sure oh
there's a dick you know there's a guy
now that guy that guy you guys
definitely got some he's got he's he
uses his rump for a certain thing now is
that now goat scroll down from each in
yeah go to the second row middle cyclist
on ya go that one that would be right
down I had no balls at all
now [ __ ] now scroll down first picture
when you scroll down Lauren but now
that's a [ __ ] ring and that's a that's a
penis in another an inane anus it goes
over your balls I know this Thanksgiving
so that'd be stuff in your [ __ ] and
somebody that yeah that's a Thanksgiving
surprise to treat that's what we call
stuffed turkey all right well good wait
in that's all right that's good that's
the image look at dumbass now if it's
true I'll be trying it out she's got
some thick ankles
yeah get those mulatto ankles I noticed
that there sometimes I've never thick
ankles are I've always been tough for me
not me cuz usually means they have
healthy like quads nah I like oh yeah by
the way you'll never see a girl with
thick ankles and no ass yeah I like I
like I don't mind the exact I was they
say things are there to support the
weight of them yeah it's it's what do
you think angles but yeah but I like
Jake handstand she's pretty hot I'd
[ __ ] a Tanner [ __ ]
yeah sure want a nice want some please
yes yes she is our sexuality is the most
playful and innocent part of ourselves
we're all offsprings of the Most High
we're all sacred beings we are all
children of mother father God in the
universe unfortunately our sexuality has
been distorted and manipulated to keep
us in a state of control disempowerment
and shame there's so much programming
and shame around our sexuality our
experiences of pleasure if we can
remember and reconnect with our
experiences as children we remember and
see how children so purely radiate their
sexuality energy
such in is what the [ __ ] are you talking
about yeah what was the relation she
doesn't know well she's cray-cray yeah
oh she's great great and she's Sun
taming her [ __ ] that's what she is
yeah everybody needs a thing everybody
has a thing why is her thing go in the
middle of the [ __ ] desert bleaching
her [ __ ] what a weird things into sex
you pull down it's also too long of a
pose [ __ ] yeah that's it reclaim her
innocence your utter [ __ ] is waiting
for this is your divine essence and
birthright home is returning to our
innocence
good luck asked Hanning yeah that sounds
like trauma it's almost like ah yeah it
sounds like single metaphysical nature
physical physical it's just don't she's
young that's it that's her that's her
label sweet she's pretty hot she's
pretty but she's [ __ ] very pretty easy
she's just young and oh she's a power
whoa hold on let's see the power like
that huh I like it missing the barbell
I'm impressed
stoked to get back to weightlifting
again how much weight do I'll be careful
when you throw out the term badass how
much weight a real competition
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of weight right good for her I
mean for a gal that's I see very pretty
yes she's just young she's young figure
things out she's lucky aa girl she's
going through all her she's she's going
through her stuff so what's all be nice
all right yeah yeah she's doing
something sweet you're very pretty
keep bleaching that [ __ ] see how it
goes man yeah
you can't through that [ __ ] though
sorry about the thick ankles she's very
attractive she's mad but I mean you know
she's built him lift things I find it
attractive now that I see the she look
she's a weight lifter
that's how Brian is I find her very
attractive she's a competitive
weightlifter I think it's hot
and I like her ankles well no you hating
on him before no like I'm deadlift
I like him but you know what I saw the
marks on her shins and that's from
deadlifting she's got you know where did
she the marks on her shins if you see
there's a picture of the see down there
well we did her shins are all nicked up
nope I see nope [ __ ] Nick yeah okay keep
going yeah this one look little nicked
all right there that's just Briggs dog
knows the bathroom from scraping that
bar on your shin I highly doubt it one
more time for laying naked on a rock
yeah more lineman on a rock with
spreading the asphalt I want to talk
about it she's very pretty very pretty
early body yeah she smells like hummus
though all right
is that it well she smells like olives
olive oil
Brian counts a phoenix celebrity theater
December 21st you come see me a boss in
the Wilbur theater on New Year's Eve one
show only at the Wilbur Boston do it and
I am in Kansas City next week next
Friday Saturday two shows Friday to show
Saturday Kansas City improv
then one night only Atlanta City New
Jersey December 14th La Joya Comedy
Store December 19th through 21st then
just announced Oklahoma City one night
two shows Oklahoma City December 27th
and then Tulsa Casino out there that is
December 28th get your tickets now at
the 5k calm also Boston Wilber I'm there
January 11th
tickets now tik calm said it dude
let's go bleacher [ __ ] and then I
must stuff this dick in yours nope
I want to have some duck and some peas
for this this that give us Thanksgiving
I want to be different
I want a duck [ __ ] turkey turkey annoys
me
no don't wants us to present I'd like to
have some pheasant pheasants a beautiful
bird
yeah breed pheasant you [ __ ] I have it I
want to leave I don't give a [ __ ] what
you're gonna eat huh I can't emphasize
enough what hi don't nobody do this for
everybody don't text me on Thanksgiving
let's see how many I have right holy
text me on my birthday and also I don't
give a [ __ ] what you're gonna eat
tomorrow dude I cannot emphasize enough
don't text me your your [ __ ] don't
post your food don't do that to me dude
yeah yeah I don't like it either I just
got to Happy Thanksgiving
from people who should know better they
should my real friends don't gobble
gobble gobble gobble
[Applause]
yes take it take it pretty bird pretty
bird pretty bird